pour être très précis sur l'histoire du
port d'armes
j'ai entendu absolument tout et je sais
que c'est pas quelque chose d'habituel
ça peut poser question c'est un j'ai
fait une demande à titre personnel
d'autorisation de port d'armes pour des
motifs de défense et de sécurité
personnelle parce que quand vous êtes
dans des fonctions à la présidence de la
république ou pendant la campagne
présidentielle vous êtes exposés vous
même et on est tout sauf un jeu qu'à moi
de mon point de vue on est exposé on
passe dans les médias
vous êtes identifié quand vous habitez
dans le même endroit depuis huit ans il
peut vous arriver quelque chose donc
j'ai fait une demande pour ma sécurité
personnelle je crois savoir qu un nombre
important de personnes ayant travaillé à
l'elysée se sont déjà vus délivrer des
autorisations de port d'armes
je pense par exemple je vais citer
sûrement j'espère qu'il ne m'en voudra
pas mais monsieur michel charasse
lorsqu'il était collaborateur de
françois mitterrand il disposait d'une
autorisation de port d'armes est ce que
monsieur michel charasse était le garde
du corps de françois mitterrand je ne le
crois pas un certain nombre d'autres
sous la présidence chirac par exemple il
y a eu des collaborateurs du président
qui ont pu disposer d'une autorisation
de port d'armes
il ya un certain nombre de
parlementaires qui dispose d'une
autorisation de port d'armes
ça fait pas deux des gardes du corps des
autres parlementaires et tout ça pour
vous dire que une autorisation de port
d'armes c'est quelque chose de très rare
le ministère de l'intérieur les délivre
au compte gouttes en l'occurrence il ya
eu un refus mais pour des motifs
administratifs
parce que la demande ma deuxième demande
de port d'armes au moment où je rentre
en fonctions à l'elysée
elle est basée administrativement sur
une première demande donc sur mes
fonctions de directeur de la sûreté de
la sécurité dans marche donc cesser jugé
pas recevable par la dlp agit c'est ce
que expliquait alors en substance
monsieur stéphane fratacci c'est que la
dlp agi juge que comme j'ai pas
renouveler une port d'armes en ma
qualité de collaborateur du président de
la république
ils disent non sur le principe ce qui
est normal s'il doit y avoir un dossier
administratif car est complet et c'est
ce qui veut pas dire qu'il ya pas de
menace et je rentrerai pas dans les
détails
voilà
[Musique]
monsieur sadi dans ce faire juste un
petit astre fait excuser sans prisches
président monsieur benalla nous pouvons
tout entendre mais il y a une réalité ce
sont les visas les attendus de la
décision du préfet de police
ll ne dit pas monsieur benalla pour sa
sécurité personnelle a demandé un port
d'armes
et comme il a les qualifications
nécessaires de lui accordons dit
monsieur benalla est chargé d'une
mission de police dans le cadre de son
action de coordination de la sécurité de
la présidence de la république avec des
forces militaires et le gspr
alors il a bien fallu que la demande
comporte une description de cette
fonction de police pour que le préfet de
police qui n'invente rien puisse s'y
référer et d'autre part je laisse de
côté les allégations que vous avez pu
avancer sur des personnes qui auraient
eu des permis de port d'armes ou
d'autres peut-être à l'elysée qui en
aurait aujourd'hui mais convenait tout
de même qu' il ne suffit pas d'être
collaborateurs du président de la
république pour se trouver dans une
insécurité tels que cela justifie une
demande de port d'armes
je veux juste relever ces points donc je
vous demande très simplement de
m'expliquer pourquoi au préfet de police
on a dit une chose et pourquoi
aujourd'hui vous dites qu'une autre
chose alors pourrait prendre encore de
manière très précise
je n'ai pas rédigé mon arrêté
d'autorisation de port d'armes cet
arrêté a été rédigé par un service qui
s'appelle la direction de la police
générale et qui a essayé de faire
rentrer mon cas qui n'est pas un cas
conformes dans les clous d'ailleurs il
est très imprécis sur mes fonctions
parce qu'ils expliquent la coordination
entre les forces militaires et le gspr
les forces militaires je ne sais pas ce
que c'est moi je pense que c'est le
commandement militaire du palais puisque
vous nous avez expliqué vous même cette
fonction de coordination des services de
sécurité monsieur loches
l'a révélée alors qu'elle ne nous avait
pas été précisée dans nos premières
auditions
et qui dit vous dites il comportait la
coordination du commandement militaire
du palais et du gspr tout à fait et donc
pour répondre précisément je sais pas ce
que le seul interlocuteur que j'ai eu
sur cette autorisation de port d'armes
c'est patrick strzoda qui est dit on va
faire les choses dans les règles et on a
fait les choses dans les règles
il a saisi la préfecture de police de
l'étude du dossier
ensuite qu'une administration prennent
des considérants je crois d'ailleurs qui
à la considérant sur la menace
terroriste qui est précisées dans
l'arrêté que personne ne dit rien sur un
certain nombre de menaces
elle est précisé dans un alinéa de
l'arrêter et donc c'est pas forcément
mes fonctions de collaborateurs du
président l'a plus que c'est qu'il y
avait d'autres menaces dans lequel je ne
rentrerai pas dans le détail mais c'est
précisé sur cet arrêté patrick strzoda
n'a dictée en rien s'est arrêté aux
services de la direction de la police
générale parce que je croirais patrick
strzoda a dit voilà il ya alexandre qui
est dans cette situation là qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire
est-ce que vous pouvez le faire ce que
vous pouvez pas le faire et la
préfecture de police a répondu
favorablement et des gens qui sont des
administratifs des juristes ont pris un
certain nombre de considérants pour
pouvoir attribuer de manière légale
réglementaire une autorisation de port
d'armes la mission de police
elle fait référence à un arrêté qui leur
permet de me délivrer cette autorisation
alors est-ce que excusez moi le terme
c'est bancal juridiquement ou pas je ne
sais pas moi même je suis pas un expert
des arrêtés de port d'armes
je dis simplement que la préfecture de
police
après enquête administrative savoir s'il
y avait eu un bien-fondé quant à la
demande
deuxième chose cet arrêté intervient en
septembre en octobre de fin septembre ou
début octobre de mémoire et donc je suis
un interlocuteur connu de la préfecture
de police et par là quand ma présence
sur la pendant la campagne
présidentielle et pour ma présence sur
les déplacements du président de la
république
donc il ya sûrement eu un certain nombre
de démarches administratives internes à
la préfecture de police
sur la base de la requête de patrick
strzoda qui a aucun cas dits alexandrie
les policiers ou alexandre il s'occupe
les termes sont inexacts donc c'est un
certain nombre de considérants qui prend
en compte
principal c'est-à-dire la menace qui
pouvait peser à un moment sur moi et
donc ils ont délivré un document qui me
permettait de justifier à l'occasion
desquelles je portais mon arme et s'est
précisée dans mes missions et je tiens à
répondre à la question qui va être posée
après mes pauses dans vos missions donc
mes missions c'est quoi c'est
l'organisation des déplacements etc
mais la mission quand vous êtes un
cabinet du président de la république
allait permanente
elle s'arrête pas là mission donc quand
vous quand je rentrais chez moi je
rentrais chez moi avec mon arbre
incluant cinq globes 43 sur moi jusqu'à
mon domicile
voilà donc messieurs benalla vous
comprenez que home est dit on a voulu
faire les choses en règle et la
préfecture de police
énoncer des motivations qui permettait
au port d'armes d'être légal a tout à
fait est ce qu'on ne peut pas en déduire
que si vous n'aviez pas eu la mission de
police relevé par le préfet de police
mais si vous aviez fait la demande
uniquement en disant c'est pour ma
sécurité personnelle
normalement et légalement le permis de
port d'armes aurait dû vous être refusé
alors c'est pas tout à fait exact comme
il l'a été au ministère de l'intérieur à
deux reprises sur des choses que je vais
repréciser encore il a été refusé à deux
reprises par le ministère de l'intérieur
sur des motifs administratifs sur des
problèmes non pas de deux d'opportunité
ou pas même si un moment sur le premier
port d'armes est intervenue une décision
de frédéric l'oréal chef du sdlp qui n'a
pas souhaité que je puisse porter une
arme pendant cette campagne
présidentielle sur le deuxième la
deuxième demande c'est un problème
purement administratif parce que je
n'avais pas renouveler en l'état en
faisant état de mes nouvelles fonctions
la demande et on avait relancé la
première demande ce qui a été refusé par
la dlp agi messieurs sûr je souhaite
terminer 6e chez les résidents sur
l'autorisation de port d'armes la
mission de police n'est pas un préalable
à la délivrance de l'autorisation de
port d'armes il est prévu par les textes
de code de la sécurité intérieure en
espèces que peut se voir délivrer tout
fonctionnaire exposés à des risques dans
le cadre de ses fonctions
une autorisation de port d'armes par le
préfet territorialement compétent en
l'espèce c'est le cas on a considéré la
préfecture de police à cons
dirais que mes fonctions étaient exposés
et m'a délivré une autorisation de port
d'armes sur la base du code de la
sécurité intérieure et j'essaie donc
quand je dis fonctionnaires ces
fonctionnaires ou agents publics
j'étais agent public finalement je vois
que vous ne connaissez pas si mal les
règles d'attribution des ports d'armes